we have a voicemail number that you
can call absolutely anytime recently
you may remember that Lauren bobert
the radical republican congresswoman
um spoke very positively about the fact that
she's going to be a grandmother despite only
being 36 years old and acted like this
is a great thing the Eggman and I by the
way I told you all the reasons why outcomes
are way worse when the younger mothers are
um the worse the outcomes are for the kids in
the United States in so many different measures
the Eggman called in and he has a different
perspective that he believes is important to
consider hey Dave I'm calling about Lauren bulbert
Taylor green whatever her name is the one that's
bragging about being a 36 year old grandparent
um Dave I know we're putting her down for that
and and it is deplorable but Jews are like two
percent of the whole entire population not even
actually way less than that I feel like Jews don't
even have children until we're in our 30s and we
only have like one or two so do you think that
just the ideology of being responsible parent
taking care of your children is going to make
the Jews and um just smart liberals die out do
you think liberals need to just spread their seed
more and be less caring about reproduction if you
want to keep our liberal moral agenda going
or our Jewish Heritage going for that matter
Shalom brother oh yeah have you ever heard of a
36 year old Jewish grandparents I'm 20 years older
than her and I'm not a grandparent yet so very
very that's very true and I I have a nine month
old so no there's a the Eggman so the eggman's
using a lot of hyperbole among other things but
he is bringing up an interesting issue which is
the fact that Lauren bobert and in many parts of
the country among folks like Lauren bobert teen
pregnancy is seen as a great thing and abortion
is seen as a bad thing it leads to grandmothers in
their 30s and it leads to this hegemonic nature of
they are having so many more kids they are more
likely to end up being right Wingers they are
crowding out liberal values and that is a concern
I mean when you it's true that the more educated
one is the later they they have kids and the fewer
kids they have it's true that the wealthier one
is on average the more you wait to have kids and
you have fewer kids and it is also the case that I
mean to talk about the Jewish Community the Jewish
Community is overwhelmingly liberal it's arguably
the most liberal voting Block in the United States
other than black Americans and it's right up there
um ultra-orthodox Jews have a ton of kids much
like Mormons do or Evangelical Christians but
that is a very small percentage of of Jewish
folks and so the Eggman is not wrong in anything
that he is saying but I don't know that bobert
cheering being a 36 year old grandmother makes
me say it's time to start having a whole bunch
of kids that that doesn't uh follow for me but
an interesting subject nonetheless let me know
your thoughts we've got a great bonus show for
you today sign up at joinpakman.com you'll
get instant access I look forward to seeing
you there it's going to be a great bonus show
everybody but we'll be back tomorrow otherwise